derrière ce recours collectif autorisé
contrat paul il y à l'histoire de
montréal est qui utilisaient en 2017
bright food de la série 5 après une mise
à jour le demandeur note un
ralentissement du téléphone des délais
de réponse en touchant l'écran
l'appareil c'est un de façon abrupte ou
gels et cessent de fonctionner plus
l'apparence de cette perte d'efficacité
loeb a déjà été porté à changer leur
appareil
d'où le concept d'obsolescence
programmée on allègue que à pau était au
courant de ses problèmes
les noms n'ont rien à faire ils sont
automatiquement conclus essentiellement
voir à qui on va réclamer le coût de
l'appareil bien évidemment et le coût de
remplacement l'appareil le recours
collectif que vient d'autoriser la cour
supérieure concerne tous les québécois
qui ont utilisé un rail fond de la série
5 6 ou 7
tous ceux qui ont effectué une mise à
jour en 2017 et qui ont eu par la suite
des problèmes avec leur téléphone des
applications qui s'ouvre lentement du
texte qui gèle dans cet atelier de
réparation bien des clients se sont
plaints dans le passé des problèmes de
téléphone
après une mise à jour d'ailleurs à paul
a déjà apporté des correctifs
ils n'ont pas forcément admis leurs
erreurs mais ils ont fait en sorte de
corriger ça ah ben dis que les plus
vieux modèles peuvent ralentir après
deux mises à jour si le système ralenti
délibérément au téléphone c'est pour
ménager la batterie pour éviter qu'elles
se déchargent trop rapidement et
maintenant à port prévient les clients
quand la batterie doit être changée pour
maintenir la vitesse du téléphone dans
la mise à jour il ya un nouvel onglet
qui apparut qui s'appelle état de la
batterie
c'est dans les réglages de textes qui
écrit dessous ça va être ça va dire si
la batterie est performante pour
l'appareil ou si la batterie est dû pour
être remplacés a pour souci que les
derniers correctifs n'ont rien à voir
avec les problèmes allégué dans le
recours collectif
la compagnie n'a pas répondu à nos
demandes d'entrevue ici vincent
maisonneuve race au canada montréal